There's something that I've heard you say.
While others have said this could be the century for India and the century for China,...
...you have said this is the century, not the year,...
...the century for the woman.
Why have you said that,...
...and what is your belief in making that a reality?
I said it because of the huge amount of potential.
Just simple statistics that are written not by one organization, necessarily the World Bank or IMF,...
...but many different organizations look at, say, if we can empower more women,...
...especially in the emerging world,...
...but also in the developed world,...
...that there is a huge increase in productivity,...
...25 to 40 percent increase in productivity.
There will be a jump in GDP in emerging markets by 14 percent between now and 2020...
...if we can have much better equality, gender equality.
So, those are the kind of reasons why I say that this is not the century of the BRICS...
...but the century of women.